the engines of India's economy are
slowing down the auto industry says it's
in the middle of its worst crisis in
nearly two decades that's taking a toll
on workers like Jitendra Kumar I've been
out of work for a month the landlord is
asking for rent the grocer's are asking
for money but I have no money to give
many who do have a job say they're
anxious factories are reducing workers
to cut costs and that means less pay if
we don't have enough farmland at home
for us to survive so people like me are
forced to find work in big cities and
even here we don't find employment for
days and sometimes months the problems
in the factories are reflected in car
showrooms where businesses slow these
brand new cars are gathering dust as
they remain unsold not enough people are
buying passenger cars and commercial
vehicles lack of demand means a serious
downturn for the auto industry which
employs more than 37 million people so
some peer reflects just how badly the
Indian economy is really doing now the
auto industry is asking government
leaders to cut taxes drop in the demand
across sectors whether it is commercial
vehicles passenger vehicles two wheelers
or three wheelers all the sectors
started be growing so we are requesting
for some stimulus package the government
says it's working towards helping the
struggling motor industry there is a
fact that as far as the present economic
data is concerned a tamil sector is
facing the problem because of some
global economy because of demand and
supply and business cycle government is
already with the animal industry and
finance ministry under the guidance of
the Finance Ministry we will find out
the solution Prime Minister Narendra
Modi was reelected earlier this year
promising to transform India from a near
three trillion dollar economy into one
worth five trillion dollars but India's
GDP growth is at a six-year low
investments have dropped consumers don't
have enough money to
and and the rural economy is struggling
I think they are promising the moon
right now currently the way the economy
is functioning and the way the
government is indifferent towards it
there is no way that five trillion
economy is happening by 2024 because you
need a certain rate of growth to reach
meanwhile Chitina and others wait in
their cramped rooms hoping for work and
the money they need to support their
families Priyanka Gupta al Jazeera you
telly